[MUSIC PLAYING]
ENO COMPTON: If
you're a Go developer,
you're probably
excited about Go 1.11.
But you might also be
wondering, does App Engine
support the new runtime?
Can I write idiomatic Go
and run it on App Engine?
ANGELA FUNK: And if you're
writing Go for the cloud,
the last thing you want to
do is worry about maintaining
and deploying infrastructure.
App Engine, Google's
platform as a service,
handles all that for you.
So you can focus on what's
important-- writing Go code.
Let's show them how.
ENO COMPTON: We're
going to show you
how to deploy a Go application
to App Engine using the new Go
1.11 runtime.
ANGELA FUNK: Now, with
the new Go 1.11 runtime,
it's incredibly easy to
write idiomatic Go code
and deploy it to App Engine.
All you need are three things--
your Go code, a YAML file
that describes your runtime,
and the vendor directory
with your dependencies.
Let's take a look at each one.
ENO COMPTON: First, we'll
write a small HTTP server that
listens on port 8080 and
responds with "hello world"
to all requests.
Our code is idiomatic
and totally unconcerned
with the underlying
infrastructure.
ANGELA FUNK: Next, we need
to specify the runtime
we want for our app.
So in the root of our
project, add an app YAML
file with just one line in it--
go111.
ENO COMPTON: And finally,
here's our file structure
with a vendor directory.
We're using Go
support for rendering
our dependencies, which the
new runtime supports out
of the box.
Also, if you're
interested in trying out
Go support for modules, the
runtime supports that as well.
ANGELA FUNK: Now that we've
finished writing our app,
let's deploy it.
It takes only one command--
gcloud app deploy.
Let's start a timer.
ENO COMPTON: While we're
waiting for the app to deploy,
let's talk about what makes App
Engine a great choice for Go
applications.
ANGELA FUNK: First,
the new Go runtime.
Not only does it have first
class support for vendoring,
it also supports Go modules.
You can use any
library framework
that makes sense for
your application,
all while writing that
familiar idiomatic Go
code that all Gopher's love.
ENO COMPTON: And you get the
benefits of Google App Engine's
standard environment.
Things like fast deployments,
building in the cloud,
managed security updates,
support for HTTPS,
scaling to zero when
the app is idle,
in addition to logging
metrics and error reporting.
ANGELA FUNK: And with
that, our app is deployed.
There it is.
ENO COMPTON: We're both really
excited about the new runtime,
and we hope you are, too.
I'm Eno Compton.
ANGELA FUNK: And
I'm Angela Funk.
Feel free to leave questions or
comments in the section below.
ENO COMPTON: Reach
out to us on Twitter,
and don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
YouTube channel
for more Go videos.
ANGELA FUNK: Thanks
for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]